One of the things you're really well know
for is the TV series Merlin, isn't it?
Yeah, yeah.
I don't really think I'm ... I think Colin
Farrell's famous, I think just a few people
know who I am, but everyone's really sweet,
and everyone's like you know .. and it's nice
when people actually like something you do,
and it's nice that people kind of er .. like
with Merlin .. people genuinely adore the
show and adore the stories of it, and that's
really important, and that's nice, when you
can actually do something and .. and you know
it make's people happy, and you know that's
the whole point of doing it, people like what
you do and you kind of go yeah!
Merlin's been going on for the last 8 months,
I'm knackered!
What have you been doing in that time?
Riding horses, having sword fights, getting
lost in forests, getting really drunk .. yeah
yeah, well in character!
And have you been enjoying as much as you
enjoyed all the other series?
Yeah, because have you watched it? It's good
fun, have you? Yeah! You know everyone's really
fucking cool. It's all very chilled, they're
all really nice people to work with, Bradley,
Colin and Tom, and it's a really nice group
of people, it's the way it should be, it's fun!